trump and biden
is when when biden first started
campaigning right i'll never forget he
went on instagram and an instagram
account i think i was the first person
to comment on instagram
when he created his first post and i
said it's official
biden's going to be announcing that he's
running i think 60 days later he
announced he's running and boom
he ran so then he goes in he's kind of
watching everybody you know it's ham and
sanders it's all these other guys pete
you know
the kamala the first one him and kamala
went at it and slowly but
surely sanders came out this person came
out that person came out and it's him so
it went from aoc and sanders camp
elizabeth warren's camp
you know kamala's camp to now let's
let's make a decision
it's going to be then when the debate
started we thought he was going to
protect
a lot of aoc and bernie's uh philosophy
socialism you know let's go out there
and you know you know 80 trillion
dollars 30 trillion dollars over 10
years for you know climate change
and then he became president when he
became president
he didn't put aoc on the administration
he didn't go out there and put a lot of
these guys on the team
he went pretty moderate let's just say
moderate he's
still left but not as left as we thought
he was going to be
came out with executive orders i think
he's the second highest executive order
since uh
fdr fdr to 20 38 32 in his first 30 days
and i think he's done 28th and i think
obama stored right after that
so then we have him today you don't see
him a lot on tv you saw trump on tv
every day
you don't see him on twitter quiet you
don't even know if he exists no one
knows what he's he could be golfing
right now we have no
he could be playing video games right
now fortnite we don't know what he's
doing right now right we have no idea
what he's doing right now
then he becomes the president and now we
have the new
you know everything that's coming out do
you think he's going to be the president
that'll be quiet we won't hear a lot
from him
he'll be a little bit center-left he'll
do some of the stuff that he needs to do
to protect the left but not
far left and he'll stay committed to his
views and he'll be controlled by wall
street that's going to impose certain
things uh we need you to do this we need
you to do this we need to do that
but there's not going to be any major
changes taking place for you
or do you think he's just getting warmed
up be patient
there's going to be dramatic changes
taking place between now and midterms
well i think there are dramatic changes
taking place i mean basically he's put
israel on notice
and of course you now have the issue of
what's happening to bibi netanyahu
and you've got the communist chinese
helping the iranians
stir up a horn in its nest they've
already issued the kinds of
orders to our military that quite
frankly i don't see them
helpful i mean his executive order is
saying that the military's got to
help transexuals that does nothing for
military readiness they're
non-deployable
i mean there's there's no way that
that's a positive sign for our military
they've already looked at the the
weapons exchanges we've got with saudi
arabia
with taiwan in other words what we've
been doing is trying to build
relationships with allies who can help
us carry out our foreign policy he said
the other day that diplomacy is now the
center of our foreign policy this is a
speech that he made
at the state department oh contraire mr
president
the fact is diplomacy is not the center
of our foreign policy
u.s interests are the center of american
foreign policy diplomacy is simply a
tool
by which you get what is best for our
country i mean
and so i i don't i don't necessarily
agree with you patrick that he's going
to be
just a center-left kind of guy i look at
those kinds of things that are happening
today and the effect it's having on our
allies
the effect that it's going to have on
our adversaries and saying
this is not helpful domestically the
idea
that we're going to solve the problem of
covid
right with nothing more than wearing a
mask and oh by the way you know airlines
have got to make sure that everybody
gets on an airplane gets tested
that you're talking years away
i mean the idea of of delays in i'm
looking out into the
beautiful mountains of virginia right
here but i'm looking at
empty parking lots in the middle of the
day the the highways are empty coming to
work
and i i live 75 miles west of washington
okay when i get on the road nowadays and
there's very little traffic
still right and the idea that we can
have this many
people out of work and they're now going
to pass additional funding that
it's going to give everybody what 1400
in the poc 1400
in their pocket to me that's not the
answer
the answer is getting people vaccinated
so that we're not going to be hit with
this plague
for psalm 101 in the old testament what
nice jewish friends of mine call the
torah psalm 101
look at what is written there about
pestilence
plagues and enemies and and that's why i
say that
most of what we need today is a
spiritual
re-awakening in this in this country it
doesn't have to be a particular
denomination
but you can't alienate christianity in
this country by doing many of the things
that they're doing
i mean socially the idea of saying the
taxpayers of the united states are now
going to pay because of these executive
orders
the people of america are now going to
pay for abortions worldwide
and planned parenthood's going to be
able to carry him out in the united
states
donald trump stopped that much to the
acclaim of
probably being the best most pro-life
president we've ever had
and unfortunately all that's being
changed so culturally
spiritually politically economically
and national security wise i don't see
biden as being particularly helpful to
what we need to be as a nation well
you're saying
far left i mean far left to me is
raising taxes you know
uh uh and getting rid of all the tax
cuts that we had the last four years far
left for me would be
you know if we go out there with the 30
trillion dollars budget over the next
10 years for climate change far left
would be let's eliminate all of college
debt to 1.5 trillion dollars which is
what elizabeth warren proposed
far left to me is ubi let's give a
thousand dollar income for every
american the whole andrew yang
so that's why i mean i see far left
because i've lived in far left so
far left then you have love so
far left to me is socialism communism do
you think he's going to go
that far well certainly if we did the
things that the vice president of the
united states wants
done and he does it legislatively
because you know we've lost the senate
the conservatives lost
the senate she now makes it she's
already done it twice now
and she's probably going to do it again
here in this hearings that are ongoing
right now
and and they're going to continue this
farce that's happening in washington dc
i don't see any of that that's unifying
to this country or good for the future
again i
come back to those 18 grandkids yep
right i mean
i the middle school ones okay
when i get home at night they say that
granddad what is this about an
impeachment
they've got the constitution that
they're supposed to be looking at and
i don't see any provision for that in
this constitution right here granddad
how can we be doing it i said because
the far left is in charge of washington
dc
i mean patrick if you think about it
the constitution has guided nearly every
president
and through this the most difficult
times we've ever had as a nation
a civil war right and so people say is
this the worst of times heck no
america survived far worse than this you
know 670 000 americans died in that
civil war the population wasn't a third
of what it is today
so i my concern patrick is that too many
people are taken
up it's okay it's going to be all right
well
i'm kind of there with you i think the
future looks bright and i don't see him
being
the far left because i don't see biden
as a true believer i see sanders as a
true believer
meaning sanders becomes president you're
not going to be able to control him he's
going to do what he's going to do
because he could care less he's been a
true believer since he got married in
russia
i don't see biden as a true believer i
see biden as a
jfk coming from there maybe he's moved a
little bit more to the left because
that's what the times have changed
and by the way this is not an
endorsement this this is not a
an endorsement i've given i'm just
saying the concerns because now that
it's validated
i understand during the 18 months of
campaign if fighting gets elected
it's going to be this it's going to be
that but now that we're here and
everybody wants to try to figure out how
to pivot and make the adjustments is it
the end of the world
i think i'm kind of with you i don't
think it's the end of the world i would
point out to you
that if kamala harris becomes the
president united states i agree all
right
it's the goose is pretty well cooked at
that point
okay i agree there i agree there so 2024
do you think 2024 biden will still run
or will
will the face be kamala what do you
think is going to happen 2020 look
i think enough people are already
finding out how
what's the right word i don't think the
guy's got you know alzheimer's or
anything but
i think he's a feeble man i don't see
him as a leader
i mean if you wanted to be a great
leader
right you get elected president united
states
the speaker of the house who is a crazy
leftist stands up and says we're going
to impeach the guy you just beat
and at that point a real leader says i
really want to be the unifier of america
picks up the phone and says miss pelosi
stop it stop it before you vote on it
because it's not
first of all he's not going to get
convicted and all he's going to do is
make it more difficult to unify the
country
but he's not really a unifier you see
he's quite frankly he's not much at all
i agree with you he's not the far crazy
leftist that kamal harris is
but the bottom line of it is god forbid
something happens to the guy
i mean he's he's older than i am and i'm
a pretty old guy
and so i don't think he's going to be
shoveling off the deck over
in massachusetts afternoon where he
lived where he once lived
or the white house but the bottom line
of it is something happens to him
she she convinces people to invoke the
25th amendment which a lot of people
were trying to get you know vice
president pence to do
he had the wisdom not to do that he had
the wisdom to make sure that
that there was a transition and the
letter he wrote
uh and i was just looking at it before
we went on there and i couldn't find the
darn thing
the letter he wrote about why he did not
do what others were urging him to do and
others included president trump
was the constitution of the united
states it's a beautifully written piece
it ought to have been on the front page
of every newspaper in america and it
wasn't
and unfortunately it's not my front in
front of me because i read it under the
record right
right here with you patrick because it's
it's right spiritually
it's right economically it's right
politically and it's a constitutional
answer
to why he didn't invoke the 25th
amendment or try to get the
all of what was going on in washington
turned upside down
and unfortunately unfortunately what
happens on the sixth
it just takes all the accomplishments of
that administration and there are many
and this basically buries them
underneath that
riot that occurred up on cap i agree i
agree with that
uh uh there's something very i don't
know what it is like
there's something very peaceful about
mike pence
i don't know how to describe it so if
you like this sort of short clip from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye